[Music]
I'm generally quite suspicious of any
claims to universalism generally because
they all seem to emanate from within the
West and tend to historically have been
tired to expansionist projects
we don't want equality with unequal men
and we can't have equality in an unequal
world a world where wealth flows
upstream a world of gross and growing
inequality that has brought us to the
brink of a planet crisis
feminism as a term is so misunderstood
that rethinking feminism is also finding
a new language in which we can anchor
the change that we want to see
when you travel in Turkey all across the
Middle East you will notice that streets
belong to men public squares belong to
men particularly after certain hours
cities belong to men so there is a
backlash
well welcome everybody and thank you
very much to coming to what promises to
be I think a really interesting debate I
know I'm looking forward to it so I hope
that you are too
this debate is part of a series in
association with Unilever which is
trying to explore feminism and gender
from cross cultural perspectives we've
had a lot of debates on feminism in
Britain and in the u.s. in the West and
I think it's actually very interesting
to try to make it a bit more
international Unilever have very kindly
sponsored not just this debate but also
three more at the how the light gets in
festival in May and first of all I'm
going to introduce all our panelists and
then I'll tell you what the debate is
going to be about first of all we have
Miriam Francois on my far-right stage
left who's a political commentator
theorist and broadcaster with a focus on
France I know French female political
journalists and my sort of job rose up
as one quite recently to complain about
her sexist the politicians were so I'm
sure you've had a lot to do that she
writes for the New Statesman The
Guardian and The Huffington Post and is
also doing a DPhil in Middle Eastern
Studies at Oxford where she's
researching Islamic political movements
in Morocco Elif Shafak
is an award-winning novelist from Turkey
she's been published in more than 40
countries she's been awarded as
Chevalier of the order of Arts and
Letters and she's also been an outspoken
defender of women's rights minority
rights and freedom of expression fin
Makai is an activist on academic
described by the Guardian as a
world-changing woman for her political
work defending women's rights she's it's
nothing
[Laughter]
she's the founder of the London feminist
Network and a regular public commentator
on feminist issues particularly male
violence towards women and is also
senior lecturer in sociology at UE
University of the West of England in
Bristol and Lina Nair is chief human
resources officer at Unilever which is
actually a hell of achievement because
she is the first woman ever to hold that
post in Unilever's several hundred year
history and is on the executive board
and before that she had a wide range of
management jobs in India and South Asia
and spearheaded the career by choice
program which was helping women rejoin
the workforce after a career break so a
pretty diverse panel and we're going to
be we we're going to be talking about
where the feminism fights for equality
for everyone who's doing the fighting
who are they defending and is it right
for women in the West to fight for
equality for women in the developing
world or should they be fighting for it
for themselves from the right to wear
head scarfs to the refusal of
contraception ideas of what is fair and
what is equal very dramatically across
the world so does feminism like a
universal girl and if it does is that
because it's an impossible dream and is
there anything wrong with white Western
liberal feminists which I suppose I'll
describe myself as fighting for the
rights of women from different cultures
should we recognize that feminism means
different things in different places or
should we all be fighting for the same
thing so the format is going to be that
each of our speakers is going to do a
three-minute pitch on should feminism
pursue a universal goal and can there be
one and then we're going to start
discussing amongst ourselves so first of
all Marion
well just in three minutes a few points
that I wanted to make I'm generally
quite suspicious of any claims to
universalism generally because they all
seem to emanate from within the West and
tend to historically have been tired to
expansionist projects and more recently
to various forms of imperialism and as
such I think that they've the discourse
on universalism has functioned as a
supporting ideology of imperialism and
continues to do so in many ways and
certainly feminism has been no exception
we saw for example the co-optation of
feminist ideals when it came to
Afghanistan when it's come to Iraq but
we see it more locally as well I've
worked on more uk-based stories related
to Muslim women and the extent to which
predominant liberal views concerning
religion take precedence over the actual
values and ideals that help women from
minority communities find their own
version of what they would consider to
be emancipation or balance and therefore
I think to a large extent what parades
as universalism masquerades as a form of
cultural imperialism and ultimately
functions as a means of perpetuating
cultural hierarchies the notion that we
in the west of purveyors of a superior
way of looking at the world and that we
need to help others benefit from that
and if they don't want to help them will
militarily assist them in seeing what's
best for them I'm also suspicious of
discourses about universes and within
feminism without our broader discussion
about inequality more broadly so to
paraphrase bell hooks how do we talk
about men and women being equal when all
men with a capital m on
call clearly there are social and
economic hierarchies so governing our
global system and it seems a little
bizarre to me to talk about equality
between women in Dhaka and women in
London when the economic differences
between people in London and people in
Dhaka are so extreme and finally I don't
agree with the gender-blind model which
I think has become quite dominant in the
feminist discourse I think what again
gets discussed in terms of gender
blindness is often the idea that we as
women have to imitate male standards in
order to achieve equality and actually
to my mind I don't know that men have
been doing that good a job so maybe we
don't want to replicate what they've
been doing maybe we need to find our own
way of doing things and maybe they've
got something to learn from that rather
than just trying to imitate what men
have been doing and considering that to
be our version of equality I think
that's chasing false dreams and I think
it's chasing also a notion of
emancipation which is tied into our
capitalist system which considers the
only value of a human being to be based
on their productive capacity so your
ability to produce X amount of money is
what your value as a human is worth and
maybe we as women who actually you know
produce real-life human people and I
think much more valuable things than
just money could could offer alternative
views on what is valuable what we should
consider to be yea valuable within
society more broadly
well I'd like to start by saying there's
probably as many different definitions
of feminism as there are people who call
themselves feminists for me
feminism is a global political movement
for the liberation of women and society
based on equality for all people now
however we define it what is agreed is
that this movement is in resurgence
today a resurgence that began unfolding
in the early 2000s here in this country
and indeed around the world sometimes
it's called a third or even a fourth
wave feminist activism is visible once
again online and on the streets
commentary and feminist political theory
is also being seen in the mainstream in
a way that it just wasn't before
you